I I was oh
that's awesome
we are back and you are welcome to join
us on this journey we are about to watch
assault on Arkham which I think is the
first and only Arkham versus film have
you seen this before I have not seen
this a lick you know I've played a
little bit of games very bad at the
Batmobile in those games very bad I'm
not sort of driving that thing I've
played a little bit very bad at that
part so uh we have not seen this and
also we saw your comments that it does
start to make sense as it reaches the
end because right now Flashpoint and
onward has been like crazy in the fact
that this is our Converse very intrigued
by this whole journey but this is our
next one chronologically we're gonna
dive in please let us know in the
comments which ones you're enjoying if
you're enjoying these watchalongs also
please do hit that notification Bell hit
that like I think it's down here Greg
always corrects me hit the things and
the buttons and the stuff because we are
gonna watch this journey with you and
remember if you're a patron you can
light it up with us beginning to end
sync to sync watch that whole journey we
don't play the actual movie because of
Licensing we're not Warner Brothers but
you can time it out with us for a whole
journey and see our resting faces
pensive but if you're not enjoy these
clips because we're diving in to the
entirety of assault on Arkham
is a not a door
it feels like drowning doesn't it when
the answer is at the edge of your cortex
but you can't seem to grasp it firmly
grasp it the answer
when it's a jar
ah what runs around a city but never
moves train uh traffic a wall
I didn't expect a test at the beginning
of this come on nigma what belongs to
you but others use it more than you do
huh
I have Google like the rest of the world
I needed to keep you babbling long
enough to pinpoint your position my what
Amanda Waller go Waller this is the
prequel to the new show
how great would that be if they opened
with like a power move like that just
off the show yeah I'll be sick it's like
a one big celebrity Cameo like Paul Dano
why didn't I quit when I was ahead
report
what's going on respond oh
is that Conroy
I think so does me do the voice of the
game whoa Batman
night vision yeah oh
violent
not bad
I liked how he moves like the game feels
from memory yeah
damn all these camera moves yeah
I think Google really has affected
nigma's game it just would change
everything
I like that he has pupils in the white
eyes in this one yeah
this really feels like they somehow like
got in there and choreographed a fight
scene live and the cinematography feels
lived in yeah
do the worm get it Edward Edward Enigma
you helped him nigma
tell me where it is some
oh
let's do it
intro meanwhile in a Dubstep video
thank you
doing the name cards thing again
wow wow
what a fun opening I love this music too
[Music]
blood splat
black spider
[Music]
Captain Boomerang I hope he's voiced by
Jay Courtney he's so good in that role
this is one of his best roles like that
and that and Jack Reacher yeah
oh is that kg Beast
[Music]
kind of Suicide Squad where is will
just a doctor we own these rights
yeah algae Rhythm helped put this
together
oh no Harley
Zen archery
all right on the drop
oh wowie
I like that they just made a video game
I just like animated a video game yeah
oh
he doesn't get to join The Suicide Squad
damn it dead shot
that was a lot in eight minutes yeah I
mean it was like eight characters in
like two minutes that was Big Willy's
stuff they all got jiggy with it
yeah man that was cool that was a cool
intro I don't know if I've seen an
animated movie start out like that
before yeah so much punch it's like a
bloody recurring nightmare
looks like we got rookies
smart expositions who knows who
[Music]
crisscross apple sauce play nice kids
I'm here to indoctrinate you convicts
into our special forces
I killed to keep degenerates off the
streets I won't work giancarlo's back I
was gonna say yeah what's in my neck a
powerful nanotech explosive
run away get yourself captured disobey
an order hell give me a right answer too
slowly
you would not take all of this trouble
just to kill us
be observe
oh oh no do we lose kg beast in the top
is this the slip knot of this Suicide
Squad verse
oh it is
oh
there he goes I just met you you can
climb anything you're going to break
into Arkham Asylum
screw that
[Music]
hello life calling himself The Riddler
managed to gain access to my computer
system
he downloaded a file containing the
identities and histories of every
current past and potential member of The
Suicide Squad it's personal now
Riddler's got one copy which is
currently locked away in the Arkham
property room is she going to be okay
that close to the Joker
we're done
he's a jerk
whatever
that's right Harley yeah your rendezvous
with a power broker who will set you up
for the break-in the power broker of
Marvel crossover it's the only live
action character she's just like hey
play fair and I'll shoot straight
jerk me around and I'll kill you be a
good convict Lawton then just animated
her like Kingpin I know she's just
Kingpin here she looks like she could
take half the criminals and job you
think Amanda Waller always hires one
extra Squad member just to kill out of
an example the one that's sassy yeah she
plants one to go like would they really
do it yeah who who's definitely not
going to follow those always a slipknot
that's why Slipknot has nine members
we even actually like for that slip knot
so it hit me in the moment but it
completely snuck back up on me reviewing
the footage and I ugly lulled so uh Well
Done Quick if you're giving it out leave
a chunk my way
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoever makes it just approximate it
I like how cinematic this one is yeah
they have a real fun with the directing
over the damn shoots do it now
[Music]
now it's the beginning of Godzilla 2014.
I mean the end of Godzilla is stupid
stupid another big crossover oh
the no way
good one good shark
I like that they gave him James Bond
Jaws teeth
and like a mohawk fin like it's almost
two minutes
[Laughter]
Squad movie so far
interesting
I wonder if the game takes place
simultaneously so like if you played the
game he's doing like Batman things you
know what I mean I wonder if they're
like right like while he's doing a
mission yeah flushing through sewage so
a guy just
you want to head top side slick
be my guest
that's kind of what I hope gun does is
like he has things for like they're
referenced yeah like a video game but
you don't have to play it yeah yeah you
know this is happening alongside I love
that because if he's doing the same
voice actors for all three mediums like
you could really do you know that oh I
saw you last time and blah blah blah and
it could be like a game yeah nice little
Easter egg yeah and grow the world
faster
guests have arrived Mr cobblepot
welcome to the Iceberg Lounge I'm just
finishing my supper
is that Ray Winstone oh maybe I've made
arrangements to sneak you into the crazy
Farm follow them to you
no
her and a looney boyfriend Nick my truck
a cigarettes and drove it into the river
just just for a laugh oh the Gotham Tea
Party
would hate for folks to say Mr cobblepot
takes your money and kills your
operatives
here you deploy tomorrow night under the
cover of Darkness
and then I never want to see any of you
on my turf again it's cool the way
they're intertwining through these
characters and this is like the first in
this universe that shows how much you
can do in one movie if you like know the
characterization yeah
shark
and interchangeable teeth and stuff it's
cool I don't think this works yeah
the rubber bullets
[Laughter]
hey you know it was dark I I thought I
grabbed the right box
how about a friendly guy my dad's name
oh that's clever I like that
lucky shot sure
let's see you do it
whoa looks like that one took a bad
bounce
laughs
oh
you got like Thor hulked
special assignment for you
I'm listening Amanda Waller Playbook
always get one on the inside one to kill
one to betray you got a whole collection
yeah
a mole to create unrest in the team did
you miss me what do you want
wowie just naked Harley Quinn
oh
oh good start
oh man
this ain't your grandpappy's Suicide
Squad you know like the old
hypersexualized Harley Quinn didn't
quite work for me because it was always
like at cost of her dignity sure but
this is working because it's like she's
in control of her like whatever the [__]
she wants to do yeah like actually works
like this take works and I wouldn't have
thought it would yeah yeah night before
a big missiles yeah
get your oxytocin up yeah the
characterization so far I'm really
enjoying I like everybody in this like
they're and they're not linear it's
different than I would have expected you
know where he put it don't you oh wow
what you talking about
yeah
whoa
oh
boss fight
where is it
who knows what these wankers get worked
up about
where is it
Chris stole a dirty bomb and hid it
somewhere in Gotham
apparently it's large enough that the
radiation would kill half the population
It's gotta be the game
it gives me the chills
ice puns
that's a great beat I don't know where
Mr J puts him
wanted a chatty Bobo doll before they
went on sale tomorrow
[Music]
good Daredevil Powers Yeah
get her back to our
will do but she got caught on purpose I
like her cowl yeah and I like the black
uh what are those called the rough yeah
let's do this oh I'm so excited yeah I'm
liking this one a lot so far
foreign
[Music]
classic zip
who's it gonna be though
it's definitely king shark I think I do
a dead ice pun though that's the
question
to sacrifice our love
oh
that was that was a quick change Cooper
did the score for this like had all the
fun just having a Vibe like
junction boxes up ahead so move your ass
so funky
oh
don't screw this up
how did you even go to say hello oh it's
Mark Campbell won't you hurry up the
white lifts are actually creepier that's
interesting
whoa dude damn it no let's move
come on dejected you know the rules
buddy I gotta phone it in
she's dead
oh smart do you know how many bodies
have come in here and body bags only to
jump out and Massacre a bunch of guards
it's kind of like a Tuesday yeah
[Music]
sorry hon Bulletproof cheers to other
holes there's a hole right there
how many bullets were in that gun so
many
yeah this will have to do
oh
man come on just like everyone in Gotham
being a creeper
plus
a lot of skin
wow she did the Jason X Jason X kill
foreign
it's that last one that really sets it
over the edge
you know it's expensive gases huh
that's him we work together once
deadhead buckshot
you know his name
[Applause]
[Music]
took 50 seconds for those to spark yeah
I don't know if that works that way it
should be immediate It's gotta go at the
beep I accidentally microwaved a Taco
Bell foil Thing Once and that was bolts
right away
nobody's supposed to be down there oh we
just snuck down here for a little part
what kind of party
oh my goodness Grace everyone in Gotham
is a creeper
oh yeah
yeah team up no
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
dude the squad has formed
slo-mo walk by yeah wasn't room in the
hallway for the camera they had to go by
the side
[Laughter]
it's that simple Reservoir Squad
the security camera's mic is where it's
toast they'll shut down all the security
cameras
a Surefire way to alert the bat plan
yesterday's footage Shark Week had his
first thought shut it Boomer
play yesterday's footage at the same
time I can do that and we can operate
Without Eyes On Us you mean Batman's or
Wallace both nice good plan shark I like
Boomer that's funny I know it's that's
aged up there yeah Frost move your ass
and the rest of you given this movie
thus far it means the most boobs in a
Batman movie I've ever seen I know
everyone's having a good time I mean
it makes sense to you to use like
sleight of hand with Gotham guards
they're leaning in you do too I'll do
too on my mark
now
yeah
I'd score that a miss you stupid
c-lister that's it
it was inevitable
[Music]
king shark always finds a way to be the
MVP yeah
shark no finally some action
[Music]
cheapers status report I've got you in
the exercise yard but you don't show up
on the cameras
must be something wrong with the system
damn it it's an old system so it takes
time takes time
Kane get out
whoa damn that was hard a lot of Mortal
Kombat moves yeah fatality get over here
let the girls go before it gets ugly
zombies mind to liberate I have
righteous work to do it's like that
scene from RoboCop I'm not in the mood
tonight says
that's good Arkham had a yellow alert
this evening
everything looks to be in place
that's Michelle he doesn't work Fridays
neither that's the Thursday crew
damn I guess Batman wouldn't know all
the guards yeah well Chris detective
we're just lucky this was contained
start following orders all of you
down Putin
don't call me
out gotta find a way to motivate them
man she just doesn't pick well she just
has bad taste in men it's really an
issue I mean this is a step up step up
you know progress incremental progress
I used to work here
didn't I mention that
come on that's what as a psychiatrist
silly and pal anyone who throws
boomerangs has some real issues letting
go
[Laughter]
some great lines in here yeah I love
they play on her psychology expertise so
much fun and it wasn't just for uh for
like a you know inadequacy joke right
right that was actually a good yeah yeah
oh that's fun
[Music]
ventriloquist Batman costume costume
today used
huh
the Easter eggs oh she got her hammer
I wonder if we paused in those like
three frames but it was too fat like
probably yeah
dang oh this is so clever yeah
Firefly oh she bought Maxi Zeus never
heard of any at least
you will just names these tricks
Freeze's gun score don't you already
have those Powers did you need more
freezing oh but it's a moment
oh these two so cute
okay
oh oh no use the your powers gun it's
Batman
[Music]
it's gameplay
foreign
cool shot yeah
it's Nora from the boys
[Music]
everyone land near the box of your own
powers yeah exactly
that does feel like a video game
they're in the crate room when they're
fighting
get up damn
like crate fight yeah
[Music]
ouch Batman
I was commending you earlier movie
come on
[Music]
cool
gee that was a great that was a good
shot yeah I mean you know he's not gonna
bite that his head off
don't tase me bro
I never miss unless it's Batman and I
always miss
no way
The Spoils of War black spider just
kicked the bat's ass
I might I'm a little chugged up
what no
what the hell It's gotta be Batman in
there
and I don't trust it where's Frosty
Frost damn it
Frost
I was wondering why black spider was in
this of all characters it's because it
suits the whole body I see you Bruce
Wayne I knew Waller would send someone
I'm too clever for her to let me live oh
genius and gerbano glasses do they have
a history I'm wondering if there's a do
you even know why you're assassinating
me
the wall says you screwed her and to
make an example Addie
question is why Waller didn't just blow
your head off with your Nano bomb it's
the same reason she needs me dead
because I know how to defuse them
oh
clever so she's got herself a new guy
I'll make five more just like her I'll
take her skin and put someone else in it
oh perfect creamy skin Jesus pull
yourself together
even dare to call you
oh that darling
oh oh no
don't run wiring of any kind past the
cells directly
The Joker cell yeah
chicken dinner it's like hot wiring cars
only two wires that's how you get out
first two hours
only two they all do the door that's the
door Hawaii
has the special crimes unit been called
in to protect the medical center
maybe Two-Face got a pair of hemorrhoids
please don't explode
shut up where's that Medical Center
it'll be at least up to Orange now yeah
geez
uh Smitty
foreign
Urban jagerman Jensen he was number one
oh poor guy I'm just going to slip into
something more comfortable
so no picking
[Music]
I think they're in the red now yeah
perhaps gotta be we're actually gonna
step down a Threat Level it's a green
we're fine yeah we're good it's all
under control
this is a special crimes unit surrender
and return to yourselves
[Music]
that worked well then like the hanged
man we are at the end of our rope wow I
hate you
yeah that was just a pun Enigma yeah I
love that counts for word play and
riddle you're not the pundler
you all right somewhat oh glad you made
it cuties he knows how to turn off the
bombs I can do it but you've got to get
me into the medical center you got maybe
five minutes before Waller figures out
what's what Next Level time villain you
got it you're here should have brought a
tank we have one
we have a Hulk we have a shark
all right
oh I'll guide you trust me
I ship them they so cute let them live
happily ever after in a cell
slide to the left
yes such good power set used in this
movie yeah
oh buddy
oh yeah I didn't think Batman would
actually do that I think uh someone put
him in the outfit that they robbed the
train in ah
right good placement of detail get him
to our Batman yeah bat Noir it's the
electro shock I'm gonna run a thousand
volts through your heads and fry your
bombs
[Music]
oh that's amazing
it's the electric shock
a massage for your break
I love that she kept the makeup that's
that's good yeah not common in these
here I am thinking these
that's John Carlo's voice I think it's
Kevin Conrad doing a voice I don't know
now it's a bad pression
I just thought the Riddler's plan would
be more clever
I don't trust
a thousand volts five bodies multiplied
by five allowing for absorption three
second pulses you know what you're doing
right no
I am getting reports that there's a
break in an Arkham you're on Red Alert
news to me finally are you in the
medical center we hit a snag spider
needed medical attention
but he's where
not again
shenanigans
hahaha
those scumbags are trying to screw me
yes those criminals welcome to the
playing board Waller
pulse
quite a lot longer
where's that facial hair I feel great
now buddy screws the wall yeah
the wall the wall just colors of the
wall do it again I don't know maybe the
skin is too thick oh no
no no
oh they were so cute
I I was oh
best gun ever
that's awesome
yes
what have they done to you it does look
like the actual bat suit though I think
I think uh Batman did to the did the
switcheroo the swap the black spider
is Batman
oh
[Applause]
I knew that sound someone's flossing
their brain
I wonder if that's a a blood smile
oh she found some makeup I like that the
makeup's applied though so the skin
bleaches Canon Amanda Waller wanted the
Riddler dead Waller what she got done
where does bad ears come from are they
under the Noir they just fold them down
yeah
famous for everybody
He does care
wow so messed up
that's awesome yeah let's just put that
together they both love that's clever
that's funny
and yes
oh you got it all wrong baby I was using
them to help you escape it'll be just
like old time oh you got him now
bunkum bunkum I don't like people
touching my stuff Buncombe Asylum it's a
kid's version PG you're out of bullets
you're gonna pull the trigger and when
nothing happens I'm gonna punch you in
the throat hold on stop counting for a
second I know there are bullets
oh no
nice
you just out crazy the Joker
that was cool
[Music]
ow
tsy should not uh Mallet it's right here
oh hope she's not
oh you jerk
guys yeah that's what I call it your one
gimmick hack let's split up
a buffalo Batman's here
yes Joker where did he go
oh you wanna get a boomerang fight with
Batman yeah it won't go well he and
Harley took their Mallet and disappeared
that's where he's hitting the bomb I
know you can see me bats poop you
brought protections
I figured I'd invite some friends to my
big blowout yep
my mama it's a jailbreak there he is
oh oh
of course
and also regular inmates and these guys
too Joe just stole a watch and he really
I like that they put her in a cream
please
oh
I need to find Joker and stop that bomb
gotta get out of here
well isn't that convenient oh
no
what are you doing
jeez that was Joe with the watch
it's almost done serving his time two
more weeks
oh
I really hope we're gonna like intense
poison ivy movie I would love that she's
such a cool villain
wow
oh okay they're about to kill Harvey
then yeah
[Music]
whoa no is it gonna be that suicide
Squadron I guess so it's just gonna be
it's always dead shot it's just always
dead shot in boomerang
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that's gonna hurt very intense boss
fight must be extremely painful for you
Now That's What I Call backup we got a
freaking kaichu oh no it's the big old
plant life
oh zombie poison ivys
nice way to do a zombie army with some
Stakes too yeah before the last of us
there was plant zombies the plants of us
hey we've got it under control Batman
you can take
also not sure you have it under control
you just shot a couple plants in the
face and there's a lot of stuff going on
we just got Bane for you that seems
going my way oh oh damn cute kid hope
she doesn't take being an orphan too hot
oh you said the wrong words yep not dead
shot don't ignite his core reason for
being if you want to win a fight Joker
Joker Joker
reload yeah you're still in a helicopter
[Music]
oh my God
it's actually kind of intense
[Music]
do the Hollywood POV helicopter crash we
need it
[Music]
good shot
I want a version of Deadshot who uses
cameras who's called good shot yeah he
just always gets the perfect shot that's
David Fincher he's real he's good shots
God the perspectives on these buildings
it's really harrowing it also reminds me
of The Matrix
foreign
[Music]
okay
it's funny that's like it's got to
explode a little realistically
devastating yeah that's what I was
expecting it's like a whole demolition
of this building but you're the one
who's always hurting me now what I'm
gonna hurt
oh
there's a bomb in that hammer yeah
careful
whoa
it's like he wouldn't fist fight
Deadshot yeah the ball
[Music]
oh yep
no
oh you've been a real pain in my ass
[Music]
punch in on the punch
dude that's cool Deadshot though that
was awesome
now you're just showing up but I'm here
for it oh they're all ready they're all
red wires
catch it
[Music]
and the Joker definitely died end of any
Joker stories he hit a good run I mean
it's time it's time what else can you do
50 years I mean come on what are you
gonna do all that just so you could kill
the Riddler let's just say I break a lot
of eggs to make an omelette
my men will get Enigma next time there
is no next time we're the U.S government
who's going to blow the whistle on us
the convicts you're going to start a
blog and expose us blog man that blog
don't they need you back in your squalid
little city they never did find the
Joker's body did they
ghosted in person and with a plane in
this movie
oh
dead shot what's up
[__]
the white shirt
oh kiddo Bang
s the credits
nice
I like that it's out of continuities
they can do whatever they wanted yeah
like I think that's its own little
bubble
it got to play yeah and I I mean it's
not as as integral to yeah like an
isolated story like this but part way
through the movie I suppose starting to
wonder like
how many of these characters get killed
off especially who is he yeah was he the
Riddler was MPG The Riddler it might
have been yeah yeah I was wondering how
many people would die and like I was
still surprised like I did not expect
The Little Couple to be so cute as soon
as they were I should have expected them
to die yeah I actually fell for the
Trope I like bought them and then I
still didn't do the thing that I should
have same
yeah no I think they did this really
nicely like they they they managed to
make it escalate and build like I wonder
if this is the movie okay yeah gray
goobler was Riddler yep uh Troy Baker
was a joke that wasn't him what I would
have sworn that was Hamel John DiMaggio
that's incredible Nolan North's College
Travis Willingham was more guy oh that's
good uh I would have sworn that was Mark
Hamill that was incredible yeah I'm I'm
I wonder if people are going to to oh we
will hear all about it we will hear all
about it I think hearing Kevin Conroy
and someone that sounds almost like Mark
Hamill fills in all the little Mark
Hamilton's like yeah I might have if it
wasn't Kevin Henry I might have listened
differently yeah totally and I mean is
it is it uh Hamill in the game I thought
you like it's Hamilton but maybe it's
him because I didn't know Enlighten us
if we're off so uh I loved this yeah
this was such a blast and this was I
wonder if this is the suicides I feel
like there's an animated Suicide Squad
where people were saying like this is
what the David Ayer movie ought to have
been or at least a good kind of
comparison as to what it could have been
yeah and uh and at least that thought
crossed my mind whilst watching this
especially when you get to the close to
the end you get the helicopter or the
Joker and Harley kind of getting pulled
off side by side and you sort of
wondering like what's Harley's true
Allegiance here and stuff I'm a little
bummed that her true Allegiance was uh
Joker not gonna lie yeah cause like I
like the I like the Harvey Harley we
have now where you know you don't know
but then she's also good and like maybe
that's just my bias because I like that
Harley take better well and the way they
played it here like I'm not uh I'm not
upset at the end like I'm I'm bummed
that It ultimately turned that way but I
think that they played it as such that
they're to me read like there was
something debate within her yeah the gun
moment and then yeah yeah and then in
the the Dire Straits of the situation
you know I think part of it is necessity
and part of it is whatever aspect of her
still you know has yeah
uh but yeah like the characterizations
The Voice Ensemble I thought was great
and just like the punchiness of the
animation the photography itself yeah
it's like I think in more recent times
especially with more like digitally
animated movies we talk a little more in
animation about the camera yeah you know
it's not you know the same as live
action but here it's like they certain
animated movies I feel like you watch
them and they don't call attention to
the camera very much whereas this is one
that does in a way that I think really
makes it yeah feel like you're watching
sort of a hybrid of an animated movie in
a live-action movie I prefer it I think
because I I was way more invested than I
usually am in elseworld stuff yeah
because I from the beginning was like I
like that I don't have to worry about
guessing if they survive for the sake of
like continuity yeah I mean like if
someone dies they can't use that
character so I liked that I was like oh
this is isolated but I didn't have that
thing where I didn't care because it was
isolated I cared more and I think that's
because it was so uh it pulled you in
with the art and it pulled you into the
animation style totally like all the
fights getting closer and like instead
of making it shaky cam it was like you
actually followed the fight and like the
choreography like you said at one point
felt like they actually like framed it
yeah like I I feel like they're actually
people in the room this to me was up
there with uh Red Hood and Flashpoint
yeah it's like the story maybe isn't
necessarily as like intricate but sure
but at the same time the story is just
what it needs to be and then everything
else surrounding it really just bolsters
it and makes it feel yeah both uh fun
and exciting harrowing at the right
moments yeah like yeah they they I think
the cool thing about watching these
animated movies and we've liked some
more than others I've enjoyed them all
to some extent but it does feel like and
again not to just keep going like live
action but you know like the DC EU as it
was was was originally set out as this
thing where it's like okay we're gonna
let you know the directors each have
their Creative Vision and watching these
different movies as much as much as they
haven't all felt connected and we've
only watched three that are connected
thus far out of the five we've now seen
like it still feels like yeah even in
the continuity and then here in
something that's slightly outside of it
the directors are each getting to bring
in their authorial voices as well as
translating you know these classic
characters and stories and what which
definitely sounds like what James Gunn
was implying with sure you know we're
gonna make sure the creatives make sure
the writers the directors they have a
unique Vision like if people are
wondering how fans can follow multiple
through lines the DC Animated Universe
sure like watching these in a row I've
not been like well I just don't know if
this Batman like it's all Batman yeah
and they're like that yeah and even in
the times where you're like okay what
exactly is the continuity it's not it's
not that hard to get past that right you
know coming out of like flash point into
Justice League War or something like
that's not as hard you know you notice
it maybe if you're paying attention you
know the characters to some degree but
it's not like a big obstacle and when I
watch Joker Todd Phillips Joker I wasn't
like when he introduced young Bruce like
I wondered if somehow time travel will
make him Bruce like I didn't I was
invested in that world and I liked that
they solidified there would never be a
Batman and I like that this solidified
that this was a Suicide Squad movie and
people would die and like we didn't
wonder who had to make it to the next
movie like we got to be like I was
shocked when they killed most of them
yeah exactly and and I think they did
nicely too too I get the sense that this
is I feel like Amanda Waller has become
one of like the most uh correct me if
I'm wrong because you can but you know
like the the most uh consistently
translated characters because even when
she's Viola like and then to here and
like here is an even more like you know
kind of even more Gruff and cut throat
if that's imaginable the wall uh she
calls herself the wall I love it
party name for herself yeah like yeah I
like the height that they gave her and
two you know yeah she's got the suicide
squad's mission but she's also got yeah
I got one person in here who's gonna
carry out my true plan yeah and uh I
think you're right she is pretty
consistent and that's rare uh because
like you know archetypal character but
she is able to be the Menace in a very
similar way even with tweaks around her
which is what you're saying and I also
like that she is able to get like you
know her foot over and control over
Batman but then Batman still has his
little moments like you know Batman like
never really beats the Joker and it
seems like he never really beats Waller
and I like that yeah and like she's one
step ahead but he also a little bit over
her and then at the end it's Deadshot
and that also gives Deadshot power
because Deadshot like he's like
Deathstroke where I'm always like if
he's so cool why does he always and this
was Deadshot this was great yeah yeah
yeah yeah totally and I thought they
drew the yeah they drew the stakes well
enough to where Deadshot gets to use all
of his many abilities he's awesome and
badass but also as the de facto leader
you do have to sort of watch him Wrangle
this in the situation is pitched in such
a way where yeah they do seem like they
have their hands full enough even for an
elite you know Marksman or whatever else
and they also did a good job with the
power set so like when he's fighting
Joker I was like Joker can never take
him hand to hand but Joker's got enough
inventiveness because of his craziness
yeah like Joker's intelligence is able
to keep up with some of deadshot's
physicality but in certain situations
and they really the whole movie played
that the bridge scene using the strength
of king shark and her cunning and like
there's just so many moments where they
nail the characterization and the powers
almost like my hero Academia where I
think of that yeah and we just watched
an episode that has a big prison raid
and this did a better job because we
were watching that we're like the whole
world most 80 of the world odd is Heroes
so like why are regular people with guns
guarding this person any point and in
this world I mean you have a lot of
powered people but I'm like I get it you
would have like an army of cops and
guards and stuff here and yeah like
while I am still like they could put a
superhero at them just throw it in there
and I get the Batman's always around the
corner but just on site you know but but
yeah having them be like held up by all
these like uh uh clearances and stuff
like that like they did nicely to draw
those bits of tension out and uh they
paid well to the setting and and two
yeah you get like you know your
requisite appearances by oh there's two
face and there's and the Easter eggs
were fun like they didn't feel
heavy-handed and I liked it like they
did a bunch of visual ones with them
that was the still like verbal ones were
like at that time with Mad Hatter like
they really like kept that going yeah
and I didn't know what to expect because
you know you see Batman assault on
Arkham you you expect I think something
that's a little less of an ensemble
piece or at least from the outside I
agree I was and and yeah I I loved the
way they drew the disarray of The
Suicide Squad the way Batman interacts
with the whole situation the switcheroo
I thought was a great idea Enigma I
thought was really well done and there
was a volume of villains like they could
have like the Arca movie I was worried
about because we like Batman was
supposed to be an arcan movie with Ben
Affleck like I heard and I was worried
because we just met Ben Affleck and I
was like you can't really do that like
super max Escape thing yeah and then
there was supposed to be a green arrow
super max Escape movie and I was like we
haven't like green arrow yet so keep
like saying they're gonna do this Escape
movie and then I was like you can't do
it in one and then this did so now I'm
like man I kind of [__] want a live
action like this showed me a thing could
exist yeah and I loved this this was uh
this was probably my biggest surprise I
think I knew Flashpoint it was gonna be
incredible because word of mouth and
because of how good the flashpoint comic
is and then I think I expected a lot
from the Red Hood because that's a comic
I love but I didn't know anything about
this and then this was exceptional yeah
I thought this would be fun and I came
out being like this is a blast it was
just you know barring those couple
moments of complaint of like ah you know
you were you got that butt shot in there
everyone's naked a little bit like the
four and a half like it's not quite a
four and a half star it's a four because
of uh yeah yeah but because of certain
moments of like oh you're leaning a
little bit past where it's like a clever
Choice into just like gratuitousness and
and I know people enjoy that as in
certain mediums but it became like
distracting as opposed to like World
building it's yeah it does so well with
it to a point for what it's doing that
when it sinks to the more obvious then
you're like ah come on I know you know
you better than this it's hardly
manipulating dead trap clever yeah
people showing up like poison ivy having
like a g string on a plants not so
clever like it's just like yeah yeah so
that's the only thing that I didn't love
but I loved so much that I was quickly
like oh that's like yeah we're good
little gripes little yeah like and and
the music the vibe the vibe which which
switched from like yeah all this dubstep
like cool ass music to them like fun
like groovy like back into baseball rut
yeah exactly it's just like vibing like
this was everything you want as like a a
a tween out of a PG-13 movie like this
knows how to do like the this is like a
smack in the middle of the bullseye of
PG-13 it's like a little bit edgy but
it's still cool and and you know when
people you know when bat when the Joker
says like you're real pain in my ass
like she said ass and here it does work
it does deliver with the coolness where
it could deliver with like a silly
haminess is such a good note yeah I
think that's the perfect way to end this
I agree that this is exactly the right
PG-13 like I love this as an adult but
if I was like 14 15 this might be my
favorite movie
you want to see what Batman is and it is
this is such a good Batman yeah love
this this was such a blast all right you
lovelies if you enjoyed us loving this
as we did leave a comment below hit that
notification Bell leave a like send this
to your friends only way we get to keep
doing these is people watch them
otherwise we're gonna watch them off
camera because it feels less weird but I
want to keep doing it on camera because
it's fun to share with you absolutely so
send them to your friends comment grow
the algorithm you know what to do and uh
we'll be back for I think Throne of
Atlantis I think that's the next one
what was he up to at the end of that
post credit scene 18 movies ago
and this time he has an excuse they're
an Arkham but we're about to find out
soon uh again leave a comment let us
know let you know who's thought of this
one let us know what you thought of this
experience and we will see you soon
reject Nation much appreciated go uh go
watch something cool this was fun
[Music]